rachid digoit infirmiers chu chalon sur
saône et président du collectif inter
blog on soit rachid hic moi merci d'être
avec nous 180 euros en plus pour les
soignants c'est un effort du côté du
gouvernement vous en vouliez 300 quelle
est votre réaction aujourd'hui une
avancée quand même pour vous non du tout
on est on est très loin du compte un le
socle de départ était de 300 euros pour
tous et et 180 euros pour nous c'est un
échec un échec du gouvernement est un
échec de ceux qui sont parties aux
négociations nous représentait donc on
est on est très en colère elle et tous
les collègues issus de la base je peux
vous dire qu'il ya des réactions qui
sont unanimes et on est on est très très
en colère ce soir alors 15000 personnel
devrait également être embauché dans
dans les hôpitaux c'est une avancée elle
qui vous paraît pour le coup il
acceptable
c'est toujours pareil vous savez pour
pour embaucher deux personnes il faut
être attractif au niveau salaire donc
vous pouvez proposer des embauches si
derrière il ya des confusions des
conditions de travail qui sont
déplorables et des salaires qui sont
enquis sont misérables
vous pouvez toujours attendre que les
collègues bas arrivent dans au niveau
des hôpitaux pour travailler alors vous
dites vous êtes très en colère comment
imaginez vous la suite des négociations
parce que voilà on le sent le
gouvernement essayait de faire un effort
a rajouté un peu plus d'un milliard
que va-t-il se passer maintenant vous
maintenez la mobilisation bien sûr et
plus que jamais on va maintenir la
mobilisation et je pense que la rentrée
va être très très compliqué pour le
gouvernement la colère et la colère
monte ça va être aussi très compliqué je
pense pour certains syndicats qui sont
partis nous représenter et qui qui se
satisfont de cette avancée qui n'en est
pas une pour nous clairement il y a
quand même eu un accord même s'il a été
arrachée et puis au forceps ça veut dire
qu'il ya une partie quand même de du
personnel qui est d'accord qui est
satisfaite
bah oui c'est ce que nous faisons et
certains syndicats qui sont qui sont
heureux de cette avancée mais ce sont
pas forcément des syndicats
représentatifs et en tout cas pas
représentatifs de la base comme comme on
peut l'être sont des gens qui sont
partis négocier pour nous et je pense
que leur base lors pas à eux être très
en colère elle va alors sa remontée ce
qu'il faut pour bien qu'on comprenne
nous finalement téléspectateurs
spectateurs de ces négociations
combien d'entre vous sont finalement
d'accord et combien justement de
syndicats ne le sont pas est ce que
c'est représentatif vraiment bas en tout
cas et aux rives nous l'escaut ce qu'on
a comme écossais qu'il ya une majorité
des syndicats qui sont d'accord elle a
quelques uns qui vont pas signer je
pense et j'espère en tout cas qu'ils
vont pas signer qui vont écouter les
gens du terrain comme nous voilà après
on continue on va continuer la lutte 1
c'est clair et je pense que ça va être
très compliqué à la rentrée comme je
vous disais également aussi pour ces
syndicats qui sont partis non
représentés sans nous défendre vraiment
puisque cette crise qu vide qu'on a
traversé je peux vous dire que après
tout ce qu'on a vécu je peux vous dire
qu'on a la rage on aurait on aurait
défendu on aurait défendu nos noms
métier comme il se doit mais aujourd'hui
ces gens là je pense qu'il n'était pas
sur le terrain au moment du comité je
pense que c'est pour ça aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont pas à taper du poing sur la
table assez fort pour avoir ne serait-ce
que le socle commun des 300 euros pour
tous clairement vous ne craignez pas
aujourd'hui une division
justement de l'unité syndicale qui va
affaiblir vos revendications
après honnêtement au niveau syndical à
la tuerie de la division à chacun c'est
un peu de la politique chacun prêche
pour sa paroisse donc c'est le
gouvernement s'en est bien servi aussi
je pense au niveau des négociations
donc aujourd'hui ça a new issues de la
base et du terrain de faire remonter
cette colère et de et de enfin se faire
représenter comme il se doit et c'est
vrai que nous on n'a pas été invité aux
ségur en tant que collectif et et
organisations on a même été décriée par
certaines organisations syndicales qui
ont dit qu'on n'avait pas notre place
aujourd'hui on voit que ils nous ont pas
représenter correctement et je peux vous
dire qu'à la rentrée ça va être
compliqué pour eux quand vous dites ça
va être compliqué pour eux concrètement
que va t-il se passer
il ya une perte de confiance totale avec
eux je pense a donc ça va je sais pas il
va falloir trouver d'autres moyens
peut-être de se mobiliser sans enjeu à
voir on va on va voir on va on va
plancher cet été et puis on va ressortir
je pense quelque chose à la rentrée
alors olivier viron lui souligner la
qualité des échanges menés avec les
syndicats et rappelé son souhait
d'aboutir à un accord il s'agit d'un
projet d'accord historique a précisé
l'entourage du ministre le maintien vos
livier verrons au gouvernement quelle
est votre réaction
oui votre façon c'est voilà ces
politiques politique qui se connaissent
tous entre eux donc bah voila si
monsieur vers ans était parti c'est à ce
moment là ça aurait été vraiment un
signal fort pour nous en tant que
soigneur qu'on était en pleine
négociation du c ur donc sa place y est
voilà ils l'ont laissé pour le moment on
verra on verra par la suite
merci beaucoup rachid digoit d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france